ever tell you about this sorcerer I knew
couldn't stop talking about how useful
they are as creatures because you can
brew potions from their blood no because
by eating rotting corpses they prevent
epidemics did he know they eat the
living as well no really upset him too
his theory collapsed
war is not exactly going our way we have
a side a northern Realms we're out of
its Realms don't you mean tameria and
Eden are no more radovitz pledge to
restore the old borders as soon as he
wins the war believe that
gotta believe something that's what
keeps us going
are we going
help me help
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
back to the trail like I said leads to
the main road and ends there
so a griffin this close to the Village
strange my thoughts exactly in the
forest of the mountains sure but here
near the main road maybe it's the war
corpses everywhere the stench of blood
burn flesh drives monsters crazy
sometimes men too we need to watch
ourselves in white Orchard and we should
leave as soon as we learn anything
looking for a woman raven-haired violet
eyes dresses in black and white riding
in from wildebe
and uh strange as it sounds lilac and
gooseberries might have smelled that
I've not seen no smell such a lady I
believe I'd remember yeah especially
hard to forget this one
plenty Travelers about though folk from
all over might be worth your while to
ask after him the Earth shall revolve
around the sun before you comprehend
these rules
got a minute
assistant professor in contemporary
history at oxenford Academy
geralt of Rivia Witcher with tenure I'm
looking for a woman long hair dressed in
black and white seen anyone like that of
course not unlike the populace I know
the horse woman of war is pure poppy
[ __ ]
horse woman of War what's that about
folks say an omen a beautiful Phantom
rides the fields at night looks as you
described her armies follow her and all
who cross her path meet with Miss
Fortune I can voucher the last bit know
where they saw her no facts interest me
not fairy tales
done drinking
then [ __ ] off
don't want your kind here
[Music]
I haven't done anything to you so just
calm down
of course no I uh you've done nothing
horses work in witchcraft
get him
ever find a Witcher
good woman is this the road to visit
[Music]
like
what's wrong
[Music]